apple really wants you to buy an m2
macbook pro and for some very specific
reasons but i say stop do not buy one
and i will explain why this is my m1
macbook pro and i have not touched it in
over a year and we told you guys not to
buy the m1 version as well just get the
m1 macbook air and it turns out that one
macbook air is now the world's best
selling laptop as apple showed off on
stage they also showed off the m2 chip
which has multiple improvements and the
fact that it is in this new macbook pro
how great it is and the fact that as a
fan to cool this thing down now when
these new macs came out with the first
apple silicon laptops we all expected
that the macbook pro would be the one to
buy even though it cost three hundred
dollars more because of that active
cooler and did some very in-depth
testing with thermals throttling we
found that the fact that it has a cooler
doesn't really help that much and even
though the m1 macbook air did get hot
and it did throttle
even if we threw the craziest test on it
for example 8k redrock exporting you
really didn't get that much faster
performance and that is actually
counting the fact that we have the base
model that comes with the seven core gpu
compared to the a core gpu in the m1
macbook pro but back then we had a 300
price gap between the base models of the
air and the pro which made the air
really a no-brainer but now with the
redesigned macbook air that comes in at
twelve hundred dollars so it's only a
hundred dollar difference and that comes
with the slower eight core graphics
option at the base or you actually get
the same price if you upgrade to a 10
core so now does that mean that the
macbook pro with m2 is actually worth
buying especially because it has that
cooler well let's go ahead and take a
look at what else was upgraded and if
it's actually worth it i think you'll be
quite surprised now the first thing that
really stood out to me at wwc is that
apple was really focusing on the m2 chip
for the macbook pro announcement and
here at the info page we see that it is
the same design and apple is really
pushing that m2 chip we have up to a 40
percent improvement in performance
compared to the m1 model six times
faster than intel of course and some
great battery life apple's saying a new
chip new chapter for the 13-inch macbook
pro but i don't really think that's true
because this same chip is available in
the macbook air and for the rest of the
macbook pro it is the old chapter this
is a design that came out in 2016.
and let me show you what else has
changed other than this ship and then
we're also going to talk about
throttling and if you really need that
fan for performance we have this
gorgeous retina display and apple is
saying see the better picture but in
reality you are not seeing the better
picture because this is the same display
that we've had for years and it still
only supports millions of colors 16.7
million compared to the m2 macbook air
that actually supports over a billion
colors now don't get me wrong this is
not a bad display
you still get 500 nits of brightness you
have better color accuracy p3 wide color
you have true tone that's nice and
convenient to switch to your environment
but the macbook pros always had a better
display than the macbook air but not
anymore now as far as cameras in
microphones you can be seen and be heard
but it's gonna be the exact same as
before and that was actually one of the
biggest weaknesses and complaints about
the previous m1 macbook pro it has a
720p webcam built in here's how it looks
like compared to the new 1080p cameras
that is actually what's coming in the
macbook air so that hasn't changed it's
a shocking difference now as far as
microphones those also have not changed
whereas the macbook air they've updated
those ones here's what it sounded like
before this is the microphone quality of
the m1 macbook airs microphones and the
m2 macbook air has upgraded microphones
and this is the quality of the m1
macbook pros microphones and they're
staying the same with the m2 macbook pro
the macbook air's microphone is actually
quite a bit louder than the macbook pros
studio microphone but i do think the
studio does sound a little bit less
boomy now as far as speakers the
speakers in here are exactly the same
they're not bad but what is shocking is
that the macbook air previously actually
sounded better it was both louder and
had better bass than the macbook pro go
ahead and take a listen
now with this new 2022 m2 macbook pro
the speakers have not changed they are
identical and i don't want to make this
a full-on comparison to the new macbook
air but that one has quad speakers now
they're going to fire upwards towards
the screen and through the keyboard
they're gonna sound even better now
personally seeing as none of these core
things and things that were an issue
before have changed that is quite a bit
of a disappointment if you're spending
this much money and a lot of people are
going to start upgrading the ssd and the
ram as well now i'll go into those
configurations and my thoughts on it but
when we take a look at this design if
you're spending that much money on a
laptop that you are going to have for
many years do you really want to have
this older design i mean maybe if you
love the touch bar that is one reason to
buy it but the fact that has an older
keyboard layout it also only has two
thunderbolt ports just like before you
don't have a mac safe charger for that
extra convenience and to free up a port
for you to use we don't have an sd card
reader included like we do with the 14
inch macbook pro and other than that
nothing at all has changed so we know
that this is going to be the next
macbook pro that's going to be replaced
as soon as apple can now i know some of
you guys can say man this has the fan
you are going to get better performance
than the macbook air and that is
absolutely correct apple's own charge
show that is 1.4 times faster compared
to 1.3 times faster with the macbook air
now of course if you're doing simple
tasks like most people do or even short
bursts during 4k editing with short
bursts of rendering that's not going to
be hugely taxing and like i mentioned
with the previous macbook air it was not
that much slower for heavy long
intensive tasks for example exporting
high resolution raw images when you're
waiting close to half hour a couple
minutes isn't a huge deal breaker and
that's also including the cheaper 7 core
model not the a core this time around we
will see how the thermal performance
does with the macbook air and also if
we're going to be able to hack it like
we did with the m1 macbook air add those
thermal pads and get it to actually
outperform the macbook pro which kind of
blows your mind how is that possible
well that's possible because apple
doesn't actually ramp up the fan soon
enough so the macbook pro does actually
throttle whereas the one that's fanless
there's no fan to adjust so when we
added a thermal pad it actually
outperformed it if you guys want to see
us using the thermal pad hack on the new
macbook air make sure you click that
subscribe button so you guys don't miss
out on that video when we look at the
full detailed specifications
what has changed other than that chip
nothing i mean the only thing they're
doing now is giving you a 67 watt
charger instead of a 61 watt charger the
battery life is the same the battery is
the same the screen speakers every
single thing is the same as well as the
prices now i know some people say i'm
buying that just because i want the fan
i want to get the maximum performance
but honestly if you're somebody that
really cares about the performance once
you grab one of these and you add the
ram because you need more ram if you
care about performance and productivity
you upgrade your storage now you're only
looking at a 300 difference compared to
the 14 inch macbook pro that not only
has way better microphones speakers
webcam it also has the larger display
that's 1000 nits sustained up to 1600
nits for hdr you have three thunderbolt
ports a separate charger you have a sd
card reader you have dual fans built in
that will actually run quieter so once
you add those you are getting so much
more bang for your buck spending a
little bit more and getting more
graphics performance and more processor
performance as well so if you're
somebody that's buying the m2 macbook
pro because of the performance and
you're going to be upgrading it i would
say don't buy it anyways spend a little
bit more money and get yourself a 14
inch that is redesigned and that design
is going to stick around for at least
another five years
with those extras and not get quickly
replaced so why in the world did apple
keep this outdated macbook and they're
selling it for the same price and they
just put the m2 chip in there well i
think it's for two reasons the first one
is because of profit margins they're
gonna make more money selling this old
macbook the way it's been for a long
time than the redesigned m2 version it
is gonna be a lot of money for them they
don't have to have that expensive screen
with the cutouts they don't have to have
mac safe included into it it's not a new
chassis none of that it's the old one
and two just to get people to want to
upgrade from it once they add those
extra you know the storage and ram to
the 14 inch model i mean even if you go
on their website and you click on
macbook pro you see that they have it on
the left hand side looking all dinky and
small and they actually put the 16 inch
closer to it which they usually don't do
and then the 14 inch to make you want to
buy that instead and that gets you to
spend more money which is true but at
the same time you are getting that
better laptop now if you're somebody
that doesn't need the high-end upgrades
that's where i would say take a look
once again at buying either something
that's lower like this or the redesigned
m2 macbook air that's also going to
stick around for a long time and does
have a screen that supports over a
billion colors and has the extra max
save charging and the other updates as
well you guys let me know your thoughts
down below we are also going to be doing
a direct comparison on those two
macbooks so if you guys want to see the
m2 macbook air vs m2 macbook pro in
detail click that circle above check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]